it is January 1st 2023 the beginning not
just of a new month but a new year so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'll talk about what I
did in December what went on what you
might have missed and what we've got
coming up in January I will also be
doing a end of the year Wrap Up Video
sort of a review of everything from 2022
but this is not that I will be doing
that as a separate video in the next few
days I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things so with no
further Ado here they are big thing
number one you may have seen the
announcement in social media after
serving for six and uh close to three
quarter years as editor of stoicism
today I have a step down from that
position and my assistant editor and
good friend and colleague Harold coveley
has taken over as editor and he's going
to be ably assisted by the new assistant
editor Judy stove so I'm really you know
quite happy about that that's going to
give me a little bit more time to work
on other things
big thing number two
worlds of speculative fiction is going
into yet another year and we did our
usual soliciting suggestions and then
doing a vote and so we have the entire
lineup available for 2023. we'll talk a
little bit more about that in just a bit
a lot of cool authors and uh series
coming up in that
finally big thing number three I am
going to be bringing out a course on
Descartes meditations on first
philosophy a course that will involve
class sessions with me and should be you
know quite good this is a text I've been
reading and studying for about uh 20
yeah I mean close to 30 years now at
this point and I've got a lot to say
about it and I think it's a really
important piece of philosophy so those
are the three big things let's now talk
about what went on on the other side of
the beginning of the year
all right so December 2022 pretty busy
month in many respects uh had a lot of
online events my usual AMA ask me
anything we did worlds of speculative
fiction beginning Dan Simmons Hyperion
Canto so I quickly realized that they
began reading that a massive set of four
volumes that we were only going to be
able to do two of them so that's what we
concentrated on Hyperion in the fall of
Hyperion of course we did our usual
philosophy chat and Hegel sessions and
all of that stuff and you know December
is always a busy time in part because
we're finishing up with academic courses
and last semester I taught one course
for Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design
which finished up in early December and
then
um three courses for Marquette
University all of those were face to
face and Marquette finishes up kind of
late so you know uh I think the the last
day of class might have been the 16th or
so but you know it wasn't until about
the 20th or 21st that I actually had all
of the final grades in and we also
finished up a class on Plato's dialogues
with light Hall where I've been you know
working with a platform I've been
hosting classes on now they've changed
their orientation so we're not going to
be doing classes on their platform
anymore unfortunately they're doing
Workforce Development but this is where
the Descartes class that I was telling
you about comes in it'll be hosted in
the study with Sadler Academy so we
finished up the light Hall stuff and now
we're moving on to um doing these as you
know on our own a lot of video work that
I did I actually got some progress made
on the half hour Hegel series I didn't
get to the very end of the religion
section but I got pretty close
um three videos released to my half hour
Hegel patreon supporters that you'll be
seeing this month unless you're already
a supporter as I release them to the
public
I also did a whole sequence of
additional videos on a text that I had
done before David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding there
were a lot of videos that I'd meant to
get to it's a text that I pretty
routinely teach and I just hadn't got to
them yet so I started working on those
and similarly with Pascal's ponce's I
had projected a whole series of videos
on that work got some done years ago and
then resumed work on it this last month
I also did a few uh quick takes videos
on topics that I thought were important
I'll probably be doing some writing
about those Topics in the near future a
couple Sadler's stories including one
about what Christmas used to be like in
the LA Marie's family that's my mother's
side of the family French Canadian
although you know living in America and
bringing uh spouses down from Quebec
back for several Generations
what else we had a wisdom for Life show
and that's episode 61 you might find
interesting about taking down time
evil Sadler made an appearance nobody
should listen to him let me remind
everybody I also finally finished up did
a lot of like you know getting getting
things tidied up and and finished up
this time uh when I did the Ursula K Le
guine Earthsea class I did about I don't
know 80 90 videos and I didn't get to
four of them that I'd intended to do on
her story dragonfly which which is quite
important it's found in Tales of uh of
Earthsea or Tales From Earthsea and so I
got those done as well and then I did
one book review on Tim Iverson's calm
and curious which is about stoicism and
education
um what else you know we had our um
podcast stuff I was working through a
lot of Cicero's on duties and published
all of those and then we held a vote
early on in the month if I remember and
people really wanted more Aristotle so I
did some Aristotle podcast stuff as well
on book three which has to do with
responsibility and you know our
different faculties
and you know I also produced some other
podcasts for uh which I've early
released to patreon supporters and I'll
talk more about that in the December or
in the January time uh because you'll be
seeing those fairly shortly so it was
good month all told had a pretty low-key
Christmas pretty low-key uh New Years
you know just kind of stayed home and
had some good food and you know enjoyed
ourselves
um it's kind of somber because you know
all the pets are gone now but I'll talk
more about that I think in the year wrap
up uh review video that I'll do either
tomorrow or in the next few days
so we have a lot of stuff coming up in
January that you might want to put on
your calendar and much of this is online
so it's pretty easy for people to
participate in it you do want to make
sure that as I'm announcing the times
you you know translate them into your
own time zone I'm in the central time
zone and you know wherever you happen to
be it's probably not Central unless
you're you know here in the Midwest or
in the Mid-South or something like that
so
um on the seventh which is a Saturday
coming up we'll have our at noon Central
time we'll have our first AMA that's ask
me anything uh you know session of the
year you probably want to get your
questions in pretty early although not
too early because YouTube tends to scrub
them if somebody puts them a day or so
in advance but you know we get so many
questions that it's hard to answer all
of them then following that at 2 p.m I
have my philosophy chat with patreon
supporters a little bit more intimate
you know not quite one-on-one but
certainly smaller setting where they get
to video conference with me
on the 12th at 5 PM which is a Thursday
we're switching up the days for this
from Wednesdays to Thursdays we'll have
our public Hegel q a and discussion
session everybody's invited to that it's
underwritten by the patreon supporters
of the half hour Hegel project
on the 14th and which is a Saturday at
noon we'll have our two-part worlds of
speculative fiction session 66 which
will be picking back up Dan Simmons
Hyperion cantos this time with the last
two books in the series Endymion and
Rise of Endymion those are really quite
excellent and I hope you can join me for
that we begin with a video premiere
where I'm talking and people can live
chat with me as the video is premiering
and then we switch to a zoom session
where we can do some more warm you know
some more uh conversation and chat about
the books and other topics as well
on the 18th if you're here in the
greater Milwaukee area we have a
face-to-face in-person event dare the
possible I have been invited to be one
of the main speakers at that it is
hosted at the I think I'm going to
mangle this name Connecticut Center you
can find out about this you know in my
uh Facebook events and also in the
reason I owe events calendar if you want
to find out details about that and I'll
be presenting in a format that I haven't
done previously so it should be kind of
interesting you know it's these uh
slides I forget exactly what it's called
doesn't matter the name of course it's
the format that matters you have a lot
of slides and you go through them pretty
quickly and you talk fairly quickly and
and convey some information and maybe
provoke some thought so we'll see how
that works on the 21st at noon I am
going to Zoom the self-directed study
and philosophy series with a video
premiere on how to do self-directed
study of Renee Descartes works somebody
who I think really deserves it
definitely somebody who shouldn't pass
over in your studies of philosophy on
the 25th we will actually have our first
session at 10 A.M Central Time of that
online Renee Descartes course there will
be six sessions each of them 90 minutes
long there is a tuition fee for that but
it's it's a you know pretty affordable
for most people we'll be doing that
using zoom and it'll be nice resources
there for people you'll see some
announcements about that in the coming
week or so on the 27th another
face-to-face in-person thing here it's
kind of a private event but people in
the area if they really really want to
go I think they can find arrangements
for it we I've been invited to start
giving talks monthly talks called
philosophy eats something that we've
done in the past this time we're doing
it with the the Women's Club of
Milwaukee so there's a meal there's me
talking about something in this case
it'll be about New Year's resolutions
and what to do after you've already
broken them and how to rethink that a
topic that I I come back to year after
year so that'll be another in-person
event and then we have another online
event the following day uh the 28th at 9
00 a.m the animal care and stoicism
Roundtable which is being hosted by
stoic hair I'll be part of that as will
my wife and partner Andy Shaka and our
third person will be Catherine coramilis
who some of you may know from various
things having to do with stoicism and
stoic hair so that should be a fun event
as well we're going to talk about you
know what stoicism has to contribute in
thinking about animals pets rationality
empathy all these important matters
um videos so I will be producing a lot
of new videos hopefully over this month
core concept videos I got a lot more
Pascal stuff to put out and then I've
got another thing that some people might
find kind of cool so I'm going to be
teaching a class on philosophy as a way
of life and we will be discussing the
cynics now the cynic Epistles
Scholars don't think those are actually
written by the people that they're
attributed to which include uh diogenes
and crates
heraclitus
anacarsus various texts of Socrates and
the socratics but these are actually
quite valuable for understanding you
know what cynic philosophy is about
and some of the practices that are
involved with it so I'm going to be
doing some core concept videos on some
selected ideas and issues coming up in
that I also have a number of we could
call them like little orphaned uh core
concept videos where I meant to do like
a whole sequence on this person and
never got to one of them
I've got like you know one on Dostoevsky
and one in Descartes these are all
thumbnails that are sitting on my
desktop I'm going to try to get through
as many of those as I can as well
and some people may find this very
interesting I'm going to be doing a
speculative fiction studies video
uh there's a set of videos rather on
tolkien's uh essay on fairy stories so I
think you know there's a lot of Tolkien
fans out there they might find that kind
of interesting also be doing some more
you know personal videos some Sadler
stories some quick takes uh evil Sadler
might pop out again we you never know
when when he's going to show up
um maybe some other things there's some
been some other videos I've been meaning
to get to for a long time and then you
know we're gonna finish up hegel's
religion section I've just got one more
paragraph yet to go and then we're into
absolute knowing and we're getting close
to the end of the half hour Hegel
project I should mention that this
coming semester
um
I'm going to be teaching academic
classes and then non-academic personal
enrichment not for credit classes the
academic classes that I'm teaching this
semester just at Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design I am teaching
um one face-to-face class for freshmen
called introduction to Humanities in
which we do some stuff on Sophocles
Antigone and Marge on some tropis
persepolis I have to pick a third text
so I'm picking
um Mary Shelley's Frankenstein and I'll
be doing some videos on on those things
as well uh the Frankenstein and
Sophocles and perhaps even some other uh
authors who I bring in to help
illuminate these for my students and
then there's that philosophy mindfulness
and life which is really a philosophy is
a way of life focused in particular on
Hedonism utilitarianism and effective
altruism cynicism and minimalism
stoicism and then a few other things as
well so they'll probably be quite a few
videos coming out uh related to that and
quite a few writings as well over the
course of this semester the last thing I
should mention uh podcast so we're just
finishing up with the Aristotle Nick and
McCann ethics book three stuff after
that it's some stuff from lucretius's on
the on the the nature of things uh book
four and then we'll have some John
chrysostom from some of his sermons that
I did core concept videos on last
semester for my classes on anger here
and then plutarchs on anger on
controlling anger as well and then you
know we'll see what we do after that
I've got a lot of different ways we
could go there's a lot of different
um podcast stuff that needs to be done
and uh you know we'll see how much
energy I have uh for for all of this
stuff coming up so I hope you can join
me on some of these online events if
you're here in the Milwaukee area I'd
love to see you at some of these other
events
um if you you know run into me say hi
and uh yeah I hope you have a great new
year ahead and that it's um Everybody
stays safe and healthy and
intellectually engaged and that things
work out well for all of you and I'll
see you next time